[MUSIC]
Hey, Android Developers.
I'm Joe Fernandez of the Android
Developer Relations team.
Today I'll explain how to record
a video of your Android app
using the new screen record
feature of Android KitKat.
To use this feature,
you'll need a device
running Android KitKat, like the
Nexus 5, and a micro USB cable.
No video camera required.
So why record a video
of your Android app?
Good question.
A video is an effective way
to demonstrate your app.
And it gives users a quick
way to see how your app works
and what it can do
before they download it.
So it's a great
promotional tool.
Creating a video that explains
how to use advanced features
or correct common mistakes is
also a great use of app videos.
Is there a question
about your application
you get asked over and over?
Record a video to show
your users how it's done.
So what do you need to use
the screen record feature?
Well, you need a device
running Android KitKat,
such as the Nexus 5.
You also need a computer
with the Android Debug
Bridge installed.
If you have an Android software
development kit installed
on your machine, then
you already have ADB.
Finally, you'll need
a micro USB cable
to connect the computer
to your device.
As I mentioned, you
don't need a video camera
to use screen record.
However, this feature
does not record audio.
So if you want to
narrate your video,
you need to use something to
record your voice as you demo.
I recommend using a
second Android device
with an app that does
high-definition voice
recording.
Here are the steps
to record a video.
First, connect your USB
cable from your computer
to your device.
Then make sure it's
working by running
a test command,
such as ADB Devices.
Type the screen record command
to start recording, and then
perform your demo on the device.
If you're doing
narration of your demo,
don't forget to turn
on your voice recorder.
When you're done with your
demo, press the Control C
to end the recording.
Finally, download
the recorded video
to your computer using
the pull command.
Here's a video I recorded using
the screen record feature.
It shows a quick walk-through
of the Android KitKat user
interface.
I recorded this video using
only commands I just showed you.
Notice that there are no hands
or fingers in this video.
This is a direct recording
of the screen activity,
including the animations
and user actions.
The moving circle is
a touch indicator.
I'll explain how to turn on that
indicator later in this video.
Here's some pro tips for
producing a great app video.
Write a rough script or outline
of what you want to demo.
The script doesn't
have to be elaborate.
Just listing a
few key steps will
help you create a complete
video more quickly.
Practice the demo a couple
of times before recording it.
Practicing will improve the
quality of your presentation
and help you discover
parts of your demo
where you can improve your flow.
Pay attention to the speed
of your onscreen actions.
If your explanation is lagging
behind your onscreen gestures,
slow down and try
pausing between actions.
Use the developer
settings to show touches.
This option displays
that moving circle
you saw in my demo video.
Turn this feature on
in the settings app.
It's in the Developer Options
page under the Input heading.
Record while you
demonstrate your app.
This makes adding narration
to your video a lot easier.
Also, remember to
start recording video
before you start
audio recording.
That makes it easier to fit
your audio to your video
during editing.
Finally, use a
separate microphone
for recording your voice.
Built-in microphones
work, but you'll typically
get better audio quality with
a separate microphone that's
held close to your mouth.
YouTube is a great way
to distribute your video.
You can use YouTube Video
Editor to do some basic editing,
including adding a
music track, which
can make your promotional
videos a lot more engaging.
If you're adding
narration to your video,
you'll need to use a
video editor application
to add your voice audio
track to your video
before you upload it to YouTube.
On Windows, check out Movie
Maker for this purpose.
On Apple, iMovie, and
on Linux, try Kdenlive.
For more details of the screen
record feature of KitKat,
check out this link.
Have a great time
making those app videos.
I'm Joe Fernandez, and
thanks for watching.